how to find your own purpose I've been
living a very comfortable live up to now
but have really lost motivation to work
or take care of responsibilities
everything is hard because I'm dragging
my feet and waiting to the last minute
to complete how does one find their
groove again or a sense of purpose when
they don't even know what they want
I know it's vague but it's how it rolls
around in my head I think this one is
the reason I put this in the list is
because I know a lot of people are
struggling with quarantine I know you
we've talked about even your own family
and issues that with quarantine just
like how it's challenging for so many
people so I think that that would be a
good one to kind of in context of the
moment we're in now
well I think Anna's question is
something that everybody can relate to
on some level right we're all looking
for a greater purpose in our lives and
we're all evaluating how we're living on
a day to day basis against some standard
imagined or otherwise of what our life
could look like so it's easy to say my
life's not working I should have this
why am I not super excited when I wake
up in the morning when I read this
question I think what's instructive is
first of all the fact that she says
she's living a very comfortable life
right so there's almost like some guilt
like my life's been comfortable so I
shouldn't complain right like I
shouldn't I should just be happy with
what I have right but at the same time
if you're dragging your feet if you're
procrastinating there's something that's
perhaps a little bit out of function at
the moment so the first question I would
ask is what isn't working like perhaps
do an inventory of what's sub-optimal
and try to set aside that guilt like you
feel like I'm it's indulgent for me
because I live a comfortable life to
make a list of things that aren't
working because I'm lucky and great I'm
grateful to have the job that I have or
the apartment that I live in or whatever
it is but if you can be rigorous and
objective in that inventory of what's
not working optimally I think that's a
starting place and then the elusive ever
elusive question of like how do you find
purpose how do you go back how do you or
if you've lost it how
you get back and I wish I could give you
a pithy answer of here's how you do it
it's very difficult right this is a an
individual journey that's gonna look
different for everybody but I think
fundamentally for everybody it begins
with an inside job like this is an
internal search right if you don't know
what your purpose is I can't tell you
what your purpose is you have to
discover that for yourself and that
journey of self-discovery requires you
to look inward also in a rigorous and
objective way to try to figure out what
it what what it is about who you are
that a makes you uniquely you and B that
you feel inspired to uniquely Express
and the only way of answering that
question or unlocking it is to not only
ask yourself those questions but to
begin experimenting right like try these
different things what do you what brings
you joy try to remember that thing when
you were a kid that you used to like to
do not because somebody told you to do
it but because you had a natural
inclination towards it as we grow older
we tend to let go of those things or we
shift our our perspective on them and
decide that they are the purview of a
young person and as a responsible adult
it's no longer okay for you to engage in
those things so the more that you can
connect with that inner child I think
and try to remember what some of those
behaviors and activities are and build
those back into your life I think is a
good means of connecting with yourself
that might lead you to some discoveries
around purpose and I also think that
[Music]
this can be indulgent
so rather than flogging yourself like
what is my purpose and I need a purpose
maybe just go help somebody else out you
know the more that you can get out of
your own way and your own self obsession
and just make yourself available to
somebody who has less than you and it
doesn't mean that you have to go
volunteer at a soup kitchen although
that's perfectly fine it could be
calling up a friend that you haven't
talked to in a long time or somebody
that you know is having a hard time and
just letting them know that you're
available to them and I think when you
build that into a habit where being of
service to other people in a selfless
way is a reflex rather than a burden or
an obligation that in my experience and
what I've seen with other people is
probably the best way to set you on a
trajectory that's going to connect you
with some kind of purpose in your life I
know for myself when I'm of service to
other people my problems don't matter or
they get smaller and the truth is when
you're the more selfless you are first
of all the happier the happier you are
it's very gratifying when you're helping
other people like it gives your life
meaning so if when I say how do I find
purpose what I hear is like my life
doesn't feel like it has meaning well
everybody can build more meaning into
their life by helping other people your
life immediately becomes more meaningful
when you're of service to others how do
you groove back be of service to others
mmm I love that that's great and
experimenting you could even do on a
daily basis you can't find your purpose
maybe your purpose with a capital P on a
daily basis but like I remember I was in
New York with my friend Anthony Denby a
long time ago and he I woke up I was
staying with him and he's like what's
your purpose today
what's your intention today hmm and and
I never do that you know I got the
specific attention and I felt kind of
like simultaneously like wow what am I
doing wrong and then also okay I just
had connection you know connection
connect um and later that day I was on
this subway that got stopped in the
middle of like the track for 25 minutes
and people were losing their minds cuz
they were busy or whatever and this will
guy next to me was like cursing and
freaking out and I instead of like just
like I started to talk to him uh-huh
because I was into
and that's like what you're saying with
experimenting you can start that easy if
you don't know where to volunteer just
yet or who to be of service to right
didn't wake up and give yourself a
purpose every morning what's today's
purpose yeah and it can be what I love
about that story is if you decided that
day your intention was was connection
and you're stuck on that subway that
just means to engage that dude who's
having a hard time on the subway and
maybe make his day a little bit better
that's it yeah man just talked with him
and talk through his problem and that's
what we did yeah yeah meanwhile there
was this weird like six-foot-five
skinhead that was making like figure
Eight's in the hall like stomping in his
combat boots that you didn't want to
look at that was scary that guy all
right New York City
[Music]